ERIC SCHMIDT: Shall we?
Which side would like to be on?
OK, good.
Well, good afternoon, and
it is my great privilege
to welcome a friend of
mine for some years.
It's interesting that the
Secretary actually grew up
in North Carolina, and after
doing very well in school
in all the obvious ways,
ended up becoming a lawyer out
of a New York legal
system, and so forth.
And at some point, he felt
the calling to go back.
It's interesting, he became
the youngest mayor of Charlotte
in its history.
And when he was
mayor, he actually
had a pretty big impact
on economic growth,
because you foolishly
became the mayor
at the bottom of the recession.
So--
ANTHONY FOXX: Only
one way to go.
ERIC SCHMIDT: It's
definitely going to go up.
So because he
turned out to be one
of the most extraordinary
mayors in America,
President Obama appointed him
Secretary of Transportation
about a year and half ago.
And since then, the secretary
has been spending his time
basically figuring out how
to get transportation working
really, really well-- all
of the issues we care about.
What I like about
the secretary is
he's a real
innovator-- he actually
cares about this stuff,
he's pushing hard,
he's pushing hard to do all the
things to lead in our country.
And I think, Mr. Secretary,
I should just say,
welcome to Google.
ANTHONY FOXX: Thank
you very much.
It's great to be here.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thanks for the welcome.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And
for some reason,
you're unveiling a
30-year program today
at Google, which has not
been around for 30 years.
Tell us about your program.
ANTHONY FOXX: Well,
periodically the Department
of Transportation has put
forth future outlooks,
a comprehensive look at the
future of transportation
in our country.
And I can't think of a
better time, or frankly
a better place, because
our country is facing
some very, very
significant headwinds when
it comes to transportation--
population growth, climate
change, there's a
number of factors.
And if we don't get ahead
of those challenges,
we're going to find
ourselves stuck
in traffic for a long time.
So rather than find ourselves
stuck because we didn't look
out far enough,
our thought process
is that we put these facts in
front of the American public,
and then we spend time
working in Congress,
working with state capitals,
and local communities--
city halls-- to figure
out how we move forward.
So the plan, the idea here
is not to be prescriptive,
it's to define the
problem, and let
the solutions
evolve organically.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So
as part of this,
you have to work
with Congress, right?
Now, you were mayor--
Now, give me that big smile.
As mayor-- mayor strikes
me as a pretty good job.
It's a defined model, and you
clearly care a lot about people
that you serve.
Here, you have to
get their approval.
ANTHONY FOXX: Yes.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So what's
your strategy for that?
ANTHONY FOXX: Well, look--
I think part of the strategy
is changing the nature
of the conversation.
In Washington, there's
so much conversation
on surface transportation,
for example, about the Highway
Trust Fund, and the
fact that we have
four more months
of funding for it.
ERIC SCHMIDT: By
the way, I did not
know this until I was reading
about it-- the highway
transportation bill
expires in May?
ANTHONY FOXX: It expires in May.
ERIC SCHMIDT: What
happens after that?
ANTHONY FOXX: Well,
what happens after that
is that state governments
across the country that
depend on these dollars
for highway funds
will either slow
or stop projects.
That's essentially
what's going to happen.
Now, right now the state
departments of transportation
are actually planning their
plan of work for the year,
and the construction
season starts in about May.
So if the funding runs out right
when they're supposed to start,
you can guess that there are
going to be some problems.
So it's a big issue.
But the point is that we've
been talking in Washington
about getting the Highway
Trust Fund replenished.
Well, what does that get you?
Well, what it gets you
is budgeting to a number,
but it doesn't help
you budget to outcomes.
And part of what we're
trying to define in this plan
are the types of
problems that are
going to impact the outcome.
What are those problems?
Number one, how we move.
We're changing how we
move in this country.
As population starts
to concentrate around
metropolitan areas
around the country,
and you start to
see more congestion,
increasing travel
times, increasing--
it has implications on how
much money we need to invest,
but also what it is we're
paying for with that money.
Multi-modal systems are going
to be needed in the future.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Multi-modal
meaning bus-- bus car, train.
ANTHONY FOXX: Choices.
Yeah, just giving
people choices.
How do we move things?
Freight?
We obviously have
a lot of things
moving around this country
today by rail, by ship, by air.
That's going to change.
We're going to have a 60%
increase in truck traffic,
we estimate, over
the next 30 years.
We have technologies that
I know folks are working on
here, and elsewhere,
on unmanned aircraft.
There's lots of ways
that we can attack
the problem of how
you move freight.
But we need to figure
it out, and start
creating the rules of the road.
How do we adapt to changing
weather patterns and climate
change-- building at a
more resilient level?
How do we integrate technology
in our transportation system,
so that we can get
more utilization out
of what we have?
And then, finally, how do we
align dollars and decision
making so that we can achieve
an optimum level of performance
in our system?
ERIC SCHMIDT: I
was actually struck
in reading the report--
the numbers are
so much larger than I thought.
America's population will
grow by 70 million by 2045.
These mega regions,
as you identify them,
will have 75% of the US
population will be there.
So this will become
the defining--
we think of America
as a rural country,
but in fact, it's going to
be these mega regions that
will define most
people's experience.
That you're concerned
about airline mergers
and consolidation
of hubs actually
making the traffic at airports
worse, for all the reasons
that you can imagine.
We have all of these issues
about pipelines and goods
and energy, and energies
in the wrong places.
And you identify all
these in the report.
How will these issues get
resolved in your judgment?
ANTHONY FOXX: Well,
the political system
has to respond,
that's part of it.
But actually, the way that our
transportation system works,
the control is
actually dispersed
among levels of government.
So, for instance, most of
your bicycle and pedestrian
facilities are developed
at the local level,
as are your transit systems.
Your highway system is
mostly state driven.
Your air traffic control
system is actually run
by the federal government,
even though they're
commercial providers that
offer the airline service.
And so, we have this
sort of [INAUDIBLE] chart
of control over our
transportation system.
And part of what the
report points out
is that, in order to build
the future that we probably
want to have-- which is one
where travel times decline,
you're able to get things
and people moved more quickly
and safely-- we're going to
have to have more coordination.
And that's going to mean not
only the political solutions
at the federal, state, and local
levels-- funding and policy--
but it also means working very
closely with the private sector
to get it done.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So let's
talk a little bit
about the
technological road map,
and you talk about
this in the report.
And you spent a
fair amount of time
at Google, and some
other tech companies,
trying to understand that.
I think it's worth
beginning by talking
about autonomous
cars, and all of that.
You and I today
rode here in a car
without a steering
wheel, which is, to me,
always a heart attack moment,
and it worked just fine.
ANTHONY FOXX: It did.
My hair kind of stood
up a little bit.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So, I think
our audience would probably
say, when will I be
in a self-driving car?
When will I be in
an autonomous car?
When will the laws allow
me, do they allow it now?
There are all sorts of
questions like that.
What's the process you
foresee-- and let's
pick cars, because
everybody here is a driver.
How does the car get
smarter in your view?
ANTHONY FOXX: Well,
we have some things
we're doing now to try to help.
We're trying to set a
regulatory framework for things
like vehicle to
vehicle technology.
But the question
that you're asking
is actually one that I
think is really important,
because the vehicle to
vehicle technology rules
estimated to take us three
to four years to create.
And the rate of
change in technology
could happen much more
rapidly than that rule.
And so, what we have
to do as governments,
we have to work on two fronts.
One, as technology
is being incubated,
we need to find ways to be
at the table with the idea
creators so that we can help
you shape those technologies
in ways that will
actually gain faster
approval into the marketplace.
The other piece of
it is, is that we've
got to look at our own
regulatory framework--
and this is not only
at the federal level,
it's at the state
and local levels,
too, to make sure that we're
being as nimble and flexible
and adaptive as we
possibly can be,
because that's what
the future's demanding.
The fact of the matter is,
is our transportation system
isn't the old, creaky
system than it used to be.
It actually can be a very
dynamic, innovative area.
But if the regulatory system
is too slow or too antiquated,
we're going to lose
opportunities to move forward.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So
in Google's case,
you're aware of our
car activities--
autonomous cars and so forth.
Does the federal government
support-- this is essentially
regulated by the states,
and the federal government
supports what we're doing.
What concerns do you have
about what we're doing?
In other words, what's the
federal government's view
of all of this initiative?
ANTHONY FOXX: Our main north
star on any new technology
is safety.
And as long as we're
convinced that it's safe,
first and foremost,
I think we, then,
are then talking
about how do we go
through the process of
getting it certified
and out into the market place.
From our perspective, I see a
lot of promise for automation
to do a lot of things
that we care deeply about.
Number one, we've
seen an 80% reduction
in fatalities and accidents in
cars since 1960, mostly because
of--
ERIC SCHMIDT: Can
you repeat that?
80%?
Eight zero?
ANTHONY FOXX: 80%-- due,
in part, to technology.
Now the technology
was everything
from the seat belt to
different lighting systems
in cars, and so forth.
But we now believe that a lot
of the reductions in fatalities
and accidents that we
take for granted today
can be reduced with the
adoption of technology.
So we're bullish on
technology, and I'm
part of the reason I'm
here is because we're here
to say that the Department
of Transportation
wants to lean in and try to
get more automation deployed.
But of course, we've got to do
some homework on our end, too.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Another area
that you are responsible for--
and I want to come
back to infrastructure
at the end of my
questions-- has to do
with aviation, and so forth.
There's lots of
questions about aviation.
There's the free
flight programs,
there's the
modernization of the FAA,
there's the whole
question of drones.
So maybe let's start with
the drone AUV question.
What is the status of
the law with respect
to personal and professional
use of drones-- AUVs-- what's
legal, what's not?
And then, as I
understand it, you
have a deadline to produce an
answer to some other questions.
Take us through the agency's
view on all of this.
ANTHONY FOXX: Currently,
commercial use
of unmanned aircraft is
banned, absent an exemption.
And so, what the
FAA has designed
is an exemption process that,
on a case by case basis,
reviews applications
that have come in.
And we're seeing many
of them come through.
We've allowed exemptions, for
example, in the movie industry,
for the use of
unmanned aircraft.
We also, simultaneously,
have been
working through the
development of what
we're calling a small, unmanned
aircraft rule that will provide
a lot more flexibility
for the commercial use
of these devices.
And that is work that's
ongoing at DOT through the FAA,
and, of course, at
the White House.
And we're moving through that
process as quickly as we can.
We know the rules of
the road need to be set,
so we can unleash
this information.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And there's
a deadline, right?
The deadline is a
year or two from now?
ANTHONY FOXX: We're
hoping, actually,
to do it sooner than that,
on the small [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC SCHMIDT: And
so small means what?
What's small?
ANTHONY FOXX: We're
defining, mostly,
the height at which
these vehicles can go.
And I don't think it's a
secret that we're talking, more
or less, about 400
feet and below.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Think of
it as ground to 400 feet
would be reserved for or shared
with these sorts of devices.
Now there's a lot of rumors in
the aviation-- and as you know,
I'm a pilot, so lots of rumors
in aviation about things--
there's a rumor that for, I'm
going to call them big UAVs,
heavy ones, they're actually
going to require something
like a pilot's license.
Is that on the table?
ANTHONY FOXX:
There is discussion
about how best to focus
on the larger ones.
And we have not developed
an agency position--
that is a discussion that is
rich and robust and ongoing.
But it becomes much
more complicated
when you're talking about
larger scale vehicles that
may compete at the same
levels as other aircraft.
ERIC SCHMIDT: The
question is, if I
have a pilot-less
airplane, who is
the pilot in the
pilot-less airplane,
and the legal mechanisms,
are they above 400 feet?
ANTHONY FOXX: Yes.
And if you looked at some of
our exemptions, some of them
are ones in which the
applicant is actually
certified that someone
with a pilot's license
is going to be
utilizing aircraft.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And again,
that's under the theory
of maintaining
separation, because you
don't want to hit these things.
If we go back to
the FAA, there is--
and you and I have
spoken about this
before-- there has been
a long-standing effort
to modernize the air
traffic control system.
And I'll just say,
it's generally
known that the
computers were basically
invented in the Stone Age,
which is roughly the 1980s,
and at Google that's
like they weren't alive.
And there were discussions
about vacuum tubes,
I mean we're talking about
seriously primitive things.
And you've inherited
this structure.
There are serious proposals
how to modernize that.
Where is that process?
Is it funded?
What are the steps,
that kind of thing?
ANTHONY FOXX: Frankly,
we're talking about NextGen.
The funding for
NextGen has actually
been below what was
originally intended.
And, frankly, for a
little while there, it
was moving behind schedule.
And when this
administration started,
the FAA actually recalibrated
the scheduled for NextGen.
And despite the fact
that we have less money
to devote to it, we've actually
managed to keep that schedule.
And so most of the back
office set up for NextGen
has actually been put in place.
We are now starting to roll out
things like optimized profile
descents-- doesn't exactly
roll off the tongue--
but it basically means
the planes can glide down
into a landing.
And that is being used
at the Houston airport,
the Washington area airports,
are now using that system,
and we're looking
forward to rolling those
out more around the country.
But that is a NextGen type
of strategy and tactic
that we are starting to see
happen out in the world.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And the
key decision there
was to assume the GPS
was highly reliable.
The GPS enables all of those.
ANTHONY FOXX: Bigger
picture-- we have a 1940 radar
system that has relatively
imprecise tracking
ability of our airplanes.
And as a result of that, we have
to have the airplanes flying
at wider separations.
When we get to more precise
tracking of the airplane using
GPS, we can actually move the
airplanes closer together.
We can do things like the
optimized profile descents.
And it saves huge
amounts of fuel,
saves huge amounts of time,
and money out of the system.
And hopefully that will get
passed on to consumers some,
too.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Well,
the other thing
is if you go back to
your 30-year report,
you're pointing out that the
crowding in these cities,
those airports are
inside those cities.
So you're going to have even
greater conflict over noise,
use, and how do I
get to the airport,
all those kinds of
things will become--
ANTHONY FOXX: Absolutely.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I wanted
to ask about the Highway
Transportation Safety
Agency, because that's
an independent agency
that reports in to you,
is that correct?
ANTHONY FOXX: Yes.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So
how does that work?
What are they telling
you about the state
of safety improvements?
Is there something
interesting that they
have-- are they
more investigative?
ANTHONY FOXX: Well, they
both track safety trends,
regulate mostly automobile
companies and manufacturers,
and they do track how we are
doing when it comes to safety
and they give us
suggestions from time
to time on things we
can do differently.
The effort towards
reducing distracted
driving, for example,
is one that NHTSA--
ERIC SCHMIDT: That means I'm
texting while I'm driving.
ANTHONY FOXX: Texting
while you drive.
ERIC SCHMIDT: You don't
recommend that anymore.
ANTHONY FOXX: I don't
recommend that, no.
Although interestingly,
one of the capabilities
NextGen will give
us is the ability
for pilots not to have to
have an auditory communication
with air traffic control,
but actually to be texting.
So it's OK to text
while you're flying,
but when you're driving,
not a good idea.
But anyway, we are
starting to really focus in
on how can we reduce fatalities
in different ways going
forward.
And that's why technology
plays such a big role, here.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So I thought
I'd ask my final question,
then get to audience and-- we're
being broadcast all around-- so
lots of questions
from around the world.
I think the question that's
on a lot of people's minds
is why is the infrastructure
in America falling behind?
And this is not a
new problem, it's
been going on for
a very long time.
But many people believe
the infrastructure budgets,
the spending, and I
look at it, and I think,
interest rates are at huge lows,
the return on infrastructure,
I think, would arguably
be very high-- think
about the interstate
highway system of the '50s,
and so forth-- so if
you're going to spend money
on infrastructure, this
is a pretty good time
to be doing it.
So why are we in
this constant debate?
And you mentioned
earlier this expiration
in May of funding, which
is, I think-- that's all
funded through a gas tax, right?
So what's wrong here?
Do we not care about
infrastructure anymore
as a country/
ANTHONY FOXX: I don't think
that it's we don't care.
And in fact, what
I've noticed as I've
talked to members of Congress
is that on a bipartisan basis,
people realize that we've
got to do something.
But it is a question of
what that something is.
And that is why this framework
that we're introducing today
is so important.
The country has
basically been riding
on cruise control with our
system for quite awhile.
And the highway system
that was substantially
completed in 1992,
the expectation
was, well, we've
got that done, we're
ready to move onto
the next thing.
The air traffic control
system has basically
been the same
since World War II.
And meanwhile,
the rate of change
in terms of where people are
moving, how people are choosing
to live more closely into
metro areas-- as opposed
to rural areas, which
is different than it was
40 years ago-- all these
changes are happening,
and our system is
basically static.
And the debates we
have about funding
are really debates about
trying to get to last year's
funding, as opposed to looking
out for a longer window
and working your way backwards
to result-oriented investments.
So I think that the
will is still there,
folks who are stuck in
traffic right now someplace
in the country certainly want
to see a solution happen.
But I think the problem
is that no one knows
what the next thing is.
And I think that when
we talk about the trends
in this report, it gives
people a window that, you know,
we can actually
choose the future.
Just like the folks
who said, you know,
the airplane can actually work.
Folks probably thought they
were crazy, when the air traffic
system was first established.
But it's been a huge return
on investment to this country,
and I think those
technology innovations
are out there in the offing.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Let's hope so.
Let me just remind our audience
that this is on the record,
and there are members of
the press in attendance.
And we have a couple
microphones here
for people's questions
on this or anything else.
I'll ask you the
first question which
was submitted-- we have
an internal systems which
asks questions-- which is,
quote, "Why is the quality,
convenience, and affordability
of public transport in the US
so far behind developed
countries in Asia and Europe?"
ANTHONY FOXX: Well, let's see.
Let me try to answer this
in very plain English.
The first reason is that much of
the responsibility for planning
public transportation
comes at the local level.
So in highly congested
parts of the country,
where folks are flummoxed by the
amount of just pure automobile
traffic, they tend to
figure out that they
need to come up with
some other options,
and that's how transit
agencies really get going.
But we don't control
whether a community decides
to invest in transit or not.
That's a local decision.
So that's one thing.
Secondly, we spend, out
of the highway trust fund,
about 20% of the dollars
in public transit.
And that has to pick up not
only urban transit, but also
rural transit, as well.
So it has to pick up
everything that we invest in,
fundamentally.
That's also a challenge
when you have a country that
is increasingly more
concentrated in more
highly congested places.
The third piece is that in terms
of how public transportation
becomes necessary, there
is a growing recognition
that land use plays a
role in that congestion
that we're talking about.
And when you have vertical,
dense development,
you have a greater need for
that kind of transit investment
then you do when you
have sprawled green field
growth, where growth
is more dispersed
and it's hard to
connect those assets.
ERIC SCHMIDT: It
just seems to me
that when these cities
were built, somehow
they were willing to
build the subways.
And now you can't
get a subway built.
ANTHONY FOXX: It's
almost impossible.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And
there's something
about the cities which need the
most amount of infrastructure
building, for whatever internal
political reasons, can't do it.
Now you match 90% of
the money in many case?
ANTHONY FOXX: For
transit, we will usually
match somewhere around 50%,
maybe a little higher, maybe
a little lower.
For highways, it
ranges, depending
on the different state.
I think in California, you
all are about 80% or 90%
local and state funding,
versus 10% to 20% federal.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So money
maybe the other issue.
Because as you know, as
a mayor, getting money
for this sort of
stuff is hard to get.
Next question is-- and you'll
hear a theme from Googlers
about where Google
operates-- "The popularity
and scale of the
Google buses highlights
a severe shortage of
public transportation.
What can and should be done for
non-car based transportation
solutions?
If everyone on 101
was taking a bus,
there would be a bus
every few seconds."
And for your
background, I believe
we operate the largest
private bus system in America,
in terms of the number
of people that we move.
And it's the only way to deal
with the fact that we want
our employees roughly here and
in a couple of other locations,
and they're spread out.
And it's been a huge success.
Now, the buses are-- you have
to use your badge to get in,
they have, of course, very
high-speed networking in them,
and people work on the bus.
ANTHONY FOXX: Well,
look-- congestion
forces folks to think
about different options.
And the importance of having
those options available
can't be underscored.
I think public transportation,
public transit,
is one of those answers.
But I don't think
it's the only answer.
I think there are other types
of uses they can be employed.
If you had a shorter distance
to go from, for instance,
the Bay Area to
here, you might have
a bicycle path that
got people here.
We're seeing that
kind of thing happened
in some regions of the
country, where bike is actually
the way people commute.
So we need to use all of the
system, all the different ways
you can get around.
ERIC SCHMIDT: The next
question is so aggressive,
I have to ask it
to you before we
get the audience's questions.
ANTHONY FOXX: I can't wait.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Welcome to
Google. "Acela Express,
Boston to Washington,
456 miles in seven hours;
TGV, Paris to Marseilles,
536 miles in three hours,
seven hours in 1962.
Is Joe Biden the only one who
loves trains in Washington?"
ANTHONY FOXX: I'm glad you know
that Joe Biden loves trains.
I'm going to go tell him that
you all know he loves trains.
I'm a little hurt that you don't
know that I love trains, too.
I love trains.
But, look, we have,
in our country,
with the Northeast
Corridor, I'm told
that there are three turns
on the Northeast Corridor
that if you could
straighten, would enable
us to run at much higher
speeds than we do today.
I don't know if we
could get to 500 miles,
but certainly appreciably
more than we can.
And the reason why
that is tough is
because you have very
expensive real estate that
surrounds that corridor.
So it could cost anywhere-- it
could be billions of dollars
just to acquire the right
of way to make that change.
But the point here
is this-- I do
think we're going to see
high-speed rail happen
in this country.
You're going to see it happen
right here in this area.
I'm seeing some
activity in Texas
and in Florida
that encourages me
that this is going to
be something that's
going to happen in this country.
And hopefully we can get it all
connected together over time.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I work
on self-driving cars,
but I'm concerned about much
simpler ways of getting around.
And it seems like a
lot of governments
deliberately, or
inadvertently, discourage
pedestrians and other
means of transport.
And two examples, LA
did a study awhile back
that found a correlation between
cross walks and pedestrian
fatalities, so they
instituted a policy
of getting rid of cross walks,
which seems a little backwards.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Really?
AUDIENCE: Also, I got here
by electric skateboard,
which is technically
illegal in California
due to a law from the '80s.
And in general, I
know a lot of people
who take their kids
to school by car, even
though it's a few blocks away.
I think there could
be a lot of benefit
by people using their legs, and
getting places without cars.
Is their a role for
the federal government
to prevent local governments
from discouraging pedestrians,
and would you like to do that?
ANTHONY FOXX: I think
bicycle/pedestrian work
is incredibly important for the
Department of Transportation
to engage in.
And it's been, actually,
one of the things
I brought from being a mayor.
As I was leaving my city
to come to Washington,
we actually were experiencing
an uptick in pedestrian
and bicycle deaths, and
it's a passion of mine
to try to make the
world safer for folks
that are walking and biking.
What can we do at
the federal level?
Couple of things.
Number one, we have the
ability to pull together
best practices, and help
local communities that
are spending probably 70% of
the dollars that are invested
in pedestrian and bicycle
assets even better,
so that they're using
the collective knowledge
around the country to
make those investments.
We also are engaging
in an information
exchange with America's mayors.
I launched an effort to
challenge America's mayors
to focus on this, and
we're serious about it,
and I think we're going to
get some good work done.
Your question about that
skateboard and the rules
gets back to a point
I was making earlier,
which is that I do think we
have to look at our own rule
and regulation processes
at the federal, state,
and local levels, and look at
the country we're walking into,
and focus a little
less on the country
that we had 20 or 30 years ago.
It was a great
country then, it's
going to be a great country in
the future, but it is changing,
and we have to change with it.
By the way, my kid would
love that skateboard.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANTHONY FOXX: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi there, I
have a question about apps
like Uber and Lift, some
of these ride-sharing
technologies-- what are your
thoughts on how those are going
to play out in the next 30
years that you've laid out
in this plan?
ANTHONY FOXX: You know, I think
those companies are introducing
a disruptive force in
conventional ride sharing
through taxis.
It may turn out that it's
like FedEx and UPS have been
to the United States
Postal Service,
and providing a level
of competition that
starts to change the
conventional industry
in productive ways.
There's still some issues
that have to be addressed,
and will be addressed at
the state and local levels
around how Uber
and Lift integrate
with the rest of the system.
But I'm encouraged
to see entrants
coming into the transportation
space, introducing new ideas,
finding new ways to put people
to work, and grow the economy.
It's really, really neat.
ERIC SCHMIDT: What's interesting
is that-- in disclosure,
Google is a part owner of Uber--
ANTHONY FOXX: Oh,
I take it all back.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Uber
actually has a pitch
where we talk about reducing
the number of cars on the road
by virtue of ride
sharing, and so forth.
So, I'm still sort of depressed
about the math in your report,
this infrastructure, I'm
going to call a deficit.
Uber and Lift are a
mechanism to make it better.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANTHONY FOXX: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The more we use
electronics and highways
for things like
tolling, the harder they
become to use for visitors.
Different regions have
different systems.
And, as a visitor from
outside the region,
there are certain roads and
lanes that I cannot take
at all, in many cases.
How is that not a barrier
to interstate commerce?
ANTHONY FOXX: Well, look, this
is getting back into the fact
that most of our road
systems are state based.
And you could see,
and probably do see,
situations where a given
toll-way system that's
used in one state may not
work as well in another state,
or at all.
Sure there are
challenges that that
poses to people who
are passing through,
but who don't happen to live
in that particular state,
but a lot of these
systems are really
developed for people who use
those systems every day, as
opposed to folks that are
traveling from some other place
to some other place.
I think this is a
question that currently
has to be addressed
at the state level,
not necessarily at
the federal level.
But I think it also
speaks to the fact
that there are areas that we
talk about in this report that
probably do need greater
federal attention.
One of them happens
to be our freight
system in having a real set of
national goals around freight
that states and local
governments help us actualize.
ERIC SCHMIDT: This is truck
freight, or rail freight?
ANTHONY FOXX: Both, all of it.
Because all of it
is interdependent.
And in order to make
it all work seamlessly,
and to realize the
potential of this century,
we're going to have to
make our freight systems
work more seamlessly.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Go
ahead, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Given the
reality of limited funding
available at all
levels of government,
what role should
the private sector
play in funding major
capital improvements
for public infrastructure?
For instance,
bringing light rail
to this area, North Bay Shore,
or of capacity improvements
for Cal Train.
And should the government
incentivize private investment
in public infrastructure?
ANTHONY FOXX: Look,
I think there's
a bright future for
public/private partnerships
in transportation.
And it has to be part of what
we add to the use of tools
that we have available to deal
with the infrastructure deficit
that Eric was talking about.
Candidly, not every
project is going
to be one the private sector
is going to want to finance.
And the most important
distinction here is to realized
that for most of our
grandparents' and parents'
generation, infrastructure was
basically government funded.
And there's a difference
between funding and financing.
So whatever projects we
come up with that obtain
private funding have to have
some revenue that spins off
to repay that
investment, and that's
why we'll see a small number of
projects actually be attractive
to the private sector.
But they will likely
be large-scale projects
that spin off some
type of revenue.
Ports are an area
where there are
a lot of public/private
partnership opportunities.
Highways, to some extent, and
we're even seeing some activity
around high speed rail
in Florida and Texas
that looks promising.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANTHONY FOXX: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: In certain
cities in China,
the congestion has become so
bad that the city is forced
to limit the amount of
cars the residents can buy.
They have to go through
a lottery system
now in some cities, if
they want to buy a car.
Going to the future
for the States,
do think with 70
more million people,
and more concentrating
in the urban areas,
do you think the US solution
for decreasing congestions
might have to be somewhat
more restrictive as well,
and whether that be at
local or federal level?
ANTHONY FOXX: It's
really interesting.
I doubt we'll get to a point
where the American public will
want to limit the acquisition
of vehicles in that way.
But what we are seeing with
the younger generation,
the millennials, is a trend
towards fewer of them actually
buying a car, more of them
moving into these densely
populated metro areas, making
use of bicycle and pedestrian
facilities.
And more of them
using ride-share
as a way of making the
trip to the grocery store,
or what have you.
This generation is an
important generation,
because there are
more millennials
today in the country
than there are boomers.
So it is a big group.
And they're going to be driving
the market in a lot of ways.
And if their activities today
are portent of the future,
it may mean that folks
are just choosing
not to buy as many
cars in the future.
ERIC SCHMIDT:
Speaking as a boomer,
it goes downhill from here.
These millennials, there's
just more and more of them,
and fewer and fewer of us.
But let me push you on this,
because one of our employees
says, "What's your
stance on using policy
to decrease urban sprawl, an
arguably outdated model that
contributes greatly
to climate change?"
How far should
the government go?
Your answer so far
has been, the reality
is that a lot of
this stuff is done
at the state and civic level.
Do you think that you and
the federal government
should take a
tougher line on this,
given that it's such
a massive issue?
ANTHONY FOXX: I think that the
federal government's best place
here is to have programs
that are flexible enough
to help communities
that are grappling
with this problem in smart ways.
So one of the things-- we
introduced some legislation
last year, today the
president announced
his budget contains a six-year
transportation funding
approach that will substantially
increase the amount of money
in public transit, for
instance, so that we can build
for the future and
deal with this problem.
I do want to say though,
that at the local level,
there's a real
important imperative
to connect transportation
and land use.
In other words, if we build
another highway lane to manage
the capacity that exists today,
and then the local government
then zones in twice
the population there,
guess what's going to happen
to that extra lane now,
it's going to get re-congested.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Well,
in fact, there's
an interesting statistic
in traffic studies
that whenever you
add more highways,
the commute stays 30
minutes on average--
that the sprawl adjusts.
So if you just
build more highways,
you don't really
change the outcome.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I guess, thank
you for being here.
Could you reflect on the
role of the marketplace
to decide versus the
role of the government
to mandate innovations
in safety and efficiency
for transportation
and urban planning,
as it impacts transportation?
ANTHONY FOXX:
Here's how we do it,
and then I'll try to
answer your question
from a normative position.
The way we do it
is, you say, I've
got a great, smart, new
idea to make vehicles safer.
And then you come in, and you
meet with our team at NHTSA,
we go and put it through the
paces, and at the end of it
we either say one
of three things.
Yeah, you're right,
this is great, go do it.
No, it's not quite
right, and here's why.
Or we've got some questions
that we need to ask you,
the testing is
incomplete, we need
to come back and
have more study on.
That's the way the
system basically works.
Now, our goal is to do for the
automobile what the Consumer
Product Safety committee
does for the toys
that your kids use, which is
that when you buy something,
you can have a confidence
level that it's actually safe.
I think that's the right
place for us to be.
It's not a desire to
inhibit innovation,
it's a desire to make
sure that what's promised
is what's delivered.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Thank you, let's--
we have all of these questions,
and then we'll wrap up.
So let's pick it up.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: Secretary
Foxx, thank you
for your emphasis on safety.
I think under your
leadership, we're
hearing the feds talk much more
about safety in transportation.
And I know we're seeing
at the local level,
from San Francisco to New
York City to Fort Lauderdale,
an emphasis on
the idea of Vision
Zero, the goal of
setting zero traffic
fatalities and severe injuries.
We know that with increasing
technological abilities
with design, know how, and
with policies in place,
we can, if not
decrease completely,
decrease significantly traffic
fatalities and severe injuries.
What can the federal level do
to support communities, again,
like San Francisco
to New York City, who
want to really prioritize
every traffic decision based
on safety?
ANTHONY FOXX: That's
a great question.
And we've done quite a bit,
not only under my tenure,
but previous secretary
Ray LaHood's tenure,
to really focus on
pedestrian safety.
When Mayor DeBlasio
from New York
announced his Vision
Zero campaign,
and we had a TIGER grant
process, $600 million,
of basically race to the top
money for transportation,
we got a great application
from New York City,
and put $25 million into helping
them achieve Vision Zero.
So we're investing in
helping communities deal
with this issue.
Let me say this,
too-- that it is not
just densely populated
urban communities
that are having a problem
with pedestrian deaths
and accidents.
It's also in our rural
communities, too.
And we've got to
figure out solutions
that address both
of those areas.
But you can count on us to be
very sensitive to this when
it comes to our
discretionary grant programs,
when it comes to the work that
we're doing on best practices
with local communities,
and frankly,
as it relates to how we help
even transit systems get built
in a way that are going to
protect pedestrians as they're
trying to get to those
transit facilities.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I think it's true
that more than 30,000 people
die on America's
highways every year.
And there's more
than a million people
who die in cars and car-related
accidents globally every year.
Every one of those is a
family and a terrible tragedy.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: In your Beyond
Traffic report, and a number
of other recent
publications, we've
been hearing more and more
about unmanned aerial systems.
And I'd love to get more of
your thoughts about what role
you think they'll play in
these future multi-modal
transportation systems, and in
the smart cities of the future.
ANTHONY FOXX: It's
a good question,
and we reference
unmanned aircraft systems
as part of our report here.
And we think it holds
tremendous promise.
Look, every year during
the holiday season,
my wife will sit
down and she will
start going online and
getting stuff for folks.
ERIC SCHMIDT: It's OK, you
can say she uses Google.
ANTHONY FOXX: I was having
so much trouble saying that.
ERIC SCHMIDT: We're
among friends.
ANTHONY FOXX: We're
You know, look, at some level,
you say, gosh, I saved a trip.
I didn't go to the mall.
I didn't go to the store and
actually look at the stuff,
I just bought it online,
so what a great thing
I'm doing for the environment.
But, you know,
whatever you bought
has to get to you somehow.
And so that stuff is
moving, and we're still
trying to understand the
impacts of e-commerce
on the overall impact on
miles traveled in the system.
What something
like UAS introduces
is a way to deal with the
fact that a trip is still
happening today on the roadways.
And if they're able to
create another platform
to make that trip happen,
there are implications.
ERIC SCHMIDT: It
really does have
an impact on infrastructure.
ANTHONY FOXX: So, we
see the value of that,
and we're working through
our regulatory system
to try to achieve
the promise of UAS.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So we
stop having cars--
you will have fewer accidents,
but there will be accidents.
And in some cases, when
an accident is inevitable,
how are you going to
decide how that accident is
going to happen?
Like, say you have
the option of crashing
to a mother with her child, or
a teenager, or a [INAUDIBLE]
on his bike, how
is the car going
to decide who it's
going to crash into?
And will that be
undefined behavior,
or will that be regulated,
or who's going to be liable?
Can you talk about this?
ANTHONY FOXX: It's a
very good question.
And it's one that,
I think, hopefully
we can find ways to limit,
maybe even eliminate,
those situations
you're describing.
But that's a conversation the
public and private sector are
going to have to have
together about how
we work on those things.
That's one of the
reasons why there
is an organization like the
National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration, to help
advise the innovator on how
to deal with those
types of problems.
The other thing
that I would say is
that-- and we were talking
about this earlier--
one of the challenges
of automated vehicles
is that they actually follow
the rules of the road.
ERIC SCHMIDT: This is
known as, they don't speed.
But it's a good question.
So in California,
it's well-known
that there are plenty of
times in the right lane, where
in fact you're going faster
than the speed limit,
and it's considered safe to go
with the flow of other traffic.
So what do we do?
ANTHONY FOXX: Yeah,
well it's a question.
I think it's one that we're
going to have to address.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Can you
imagine the highway patrol
pulling over the
self-driving car?
ANTHONY FOXX: That is really
blowing my mind right now,
Eric.
ERIC SCHMIDT: OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Given that
different agencies are
responsible for different
modes at different levels
of jurisdiction, is there a mode
split that this vision document
has in mind, sort
of broadly speaking,
so that the federal agencies
can nudge the different state
and local level agencies
towards that mode share?
Do you see this effort to be a
compilation of best practices,
wherever federal agencies can't?
ANTHONY FOXX: The
document is really
focused on breaking open
a conversation we need
to have as a country-- holding
our system up and letting
folks see it from
the inside out.
And beginning the conversation
about whether this is the way
we're going to move
into the future.
My own personal belief
is that this system
has served us incredibly
well across the board.
It's really, across the board,
one of the finest systems,
if not the finest system,
the world has ever known.
But we've got to take
better care of what we have.
We've got to create new
capacity where we need it,
and we need it to be
smarter, so that we're
using every bit of space
and ingenuity that we have.
But the way to do
that, I think, is
going to be creating
greater coordination
among these entities.
I don't think we're going to
be able to un-ring the bell,
so to speak, on the
states' work on the highway
system, or local
communities on transit,
or the federal rail
administration-- which
the railroads are basically
private systems-- I don't know
that that's going to
necessarily change.
But I think what
can change is having
all of those entities
working more closely together
in a more fully integrated
and seamless system,
so that we can advance
mobility in the 21st century.
AUDIENCE: So since
we're among friends,
could you tell us a story about
a negotiation with Congress,
or opposition or whatever, that
left you completely shocked
and in disbelief?
ANTHONY FOXX: Shocked and
in disbelief-- well, I'll
tell you, last year,
this time last year,
we started putting out a
highway trust fund ticker.
This was literally
like a clock that
was going backwards in time
towards the point at which we
would run out of money, because
we were facing the same cliff
last year that we're facing
in the next four months.
And I spent a lot of time
going around Congress,
and talking about the need for a
long-term bill, and everything.
And on the eve of
running out of money,
Congress passed a
10-month extension.
Now, this is the 32nd
short-term extension
we've had in the last six years.
ERIC SCHMIDT: My god.
AUDIENCE: Really?
ANTHONY FOXX: Yes.
And so, think about this--
think about if you're
a state department
of transportation,
you've got big projects you
want to do that take two, three,
four years, and you've
got 10 months of funding.
The problem we have is
that the country has really
slowed down its planning
process, which is slowing down
the ability to get
these projects done,
which is affecting jobs, travel
times, and everything else.
That's pretty shocking.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I
remember, there's
an FAA control tower that
needed to be upgraded.
They would not pay the
FAA re-authorization,
they had to shut
down half the FAA,
then they had to
rebuild the tower
and it cost twice as much.
It was crazy-- complete
waste of the citizens' money.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: So, related
to the whole idea
of more collaboration
between modes,
how are you going to fund
that for research and data
across modes?
Because I know that that's a
huge problem-- it's hard enough
to fund infrastructure,
it's even more
difficult to fund research
in infrastructure needed
to conduct all of
the operations.
ANTHONY FOXX: Well, I'm
glad you mentioned this
because in the
president's budget today,
you'll be happy to know
that there was $145 million
dedicated to the study
of automated vehicles.
And that's a specific line
item in the president's budget.
More generally, we do
believe in research.
We work with a number
of universities
across the country on a
wide variety of issues.
We have studies that are
going on with universities
on the use of
biofuels in aviation.
We're looking at connected
vehicle technologies,
automated vehicles,
any number of things.
Frankly, the percentage of GDP
in transportation research,
as our plan shows, has decreased
about 0.7% of GDP, down 0.01,
I think it is.
And so we've gone down in
terms of research dollars,
but we're still very
bullish, because we've
seen the results
of that innovation,
including the work on
the automated vehicle.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And you have the
honor of the last question.
AUDIENCE: With regards
to this small UAS rule,
I'm sure we can agree that
an operation over a populous
area, or a private farm area,
as well as the size, weight,
and kinetic energy of
the vehicle, drastically
changes the profile.
What are your thoughts on
taking this risk-based approach
to regulation, as
other countries have?
ANTHONY FOXX: We're working
through our own process
for creating the footprint
for the innovation.
But the good news is, is
that we have been working
on this for awhile, and
I think it's coming.
It's coming sooner
than you know.
ERIC SCHMIDT: There's
a precedent that when
you change the GPS
approach, as you
do something called RMP,
which is the rule about how
accurate the receiver
of the airplane
is-- in other words, whatever
receiver you have then
determines what your rules are.
So it was about the object,
not some blanket rule.
That's, I think, the right
direction, in my opinion.
I think for all of you, Google
has many, many initiatives
in transportation.
We care an awful lot
about things in the air,
and obviously all the
transportation issues.
There are many--
and of our course
our employees have
many comments as well.
It is unprecedented,
Mr. Secretary,
for you to bring
your entire team here
to talk to us, to see what we're
doing, as a show of, I think,
support for American innovation.
And frankly, I think
to our audience,
this is why the president
made the right choice
in putting my friend in as the
Secretary of Transportation.
And I think you're clearly going
to be a great, great leader
for America for
many years to come.
Thank you so much for coming.
ANTHONY FOXX: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Thank
you very much.
ANTHONY FOXX: Thank you
very much, I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]